that's why we're starting with studying
the new tree Said's holy war two point
oh so who should we get rid of everybody
was not just recently bill o'reilly
called Fox News audience to arms because
it was time to start a holy war against
Isis the holy warriors here I thought
well that's has a great idea how can I
help maybe I'll hit the streets of
Washington DC to find out what the
people think about it are you interested
in signing up to the holy war probably
Louis it's pretty good they've got some
slogans I think I thank you and I
interest you in signing up in the
holding room are you interested in
joining the holy war I'd watain probably
about four foot today or what how long
it will be about 30 years I guess I
can't I can't fit in this I've great
traveling put it so that same thing you
don't have 30 years no understand by the
people of Washington they say are a
little bit skeptical of the holy war but
there's one group who probably aren't
and that's conservatives let's see what
the guys at CPAC think we're signing
people up to go to Syria to fight Syria
to fight Isis be excited about that boy
your mum yo yo get rid of them like yeah
Syria and now we go to win this time
yeah mitcham like we did the last time
yeah I got college man I even know i
agree with you i really do I we do
that's good there you guys are doing
pretty cool all right somebody's to
fight against to meet up yeah buddy guys
are doing it I have a certain battle
here that's that's I'm totally involved
in and I can't just like drop it to go
over I obviously disdain everything that
I systems I understand I understand Isis
is on our doorstep you've no commitments
tell me which religion looking forward
to getting rid of the most it'll be as
long why
just put like this they're very much
away from the Word of God with what
religion do you want to get rid of first
well Mohammed suspected he told that
very wealthy wife again that he thought
he was fearing horses they say too we've
got some snappy slogans let's not lose
our heads kill Isis dead I would follow
Bill O'Reilly into battle he has
experience he's led mini cavalry trophy
for ya he was in Buenos Aires when it
fell to the Nazis good g'head g'head you
can keep that one I don't break for
Islamic states congratulations sir Jonah
you will now be able to kill as many
people that aren't Christian as you like
Thank Pettis do it was great honor we
don't we just want him to leave he's
like Bill Murray from what about Bob
he's just never gone